あれは確か
2年前の話だあの頃からもやしようともモヤシ男と呼ばれその屈辱を晴らすべく
キング言う度に手を出しただが食べることはできなかった
結果的に全部食べてたんですけどネ実はに3時間かかってまして
あんなの食べたんですねはいらーそれから私はもやし燃やすとどの知られ今に
こんにちははじめ社長です
姉から2年がたった俺は強くなり家からフェリーで本物の神となったあの頃取ると違っ
ていくと俺覚えスノーする人間全員に今日は俺の進化させギター
見てりゃらーっそんなねやっててない
ですよ痩せてますけど消せますけどガリガリじゃなくてやっぱりがタンクないんですよ
野菜があったぐらいです今日はキング牛丼おりベンツたいと思いますあの頃はもう本当
にただのもやしだったもう色で細すぎで全然食べたかったんですけどもおかしい食べ
なくなってから勝点を受けがすごいんですよ
まあ一の峰食欲が人並みにすごいんでなんかね食べれますよ多分金融の今日番号ポップ
派
ご覧くださいねが10度を2つです
いやいけれ俺絶対いけるか今日はまずで言ってるなに足ぜぃあの頃の俺とは違ってる
けどキングゲーじゃ普通あの女ないんですけどサイズ的には目がキュート2つ分
らしいですさあ行く芸見せてやるからの今日は
みんな約束してくれ俺がもし競歩のキング牛丼を食べきったら
っっ
俺のことはもう燃やすと呼ばないてくもうおやつ通わせないかな
でまぁちょっと下達的に全部5しま一つ
いやんもうあの頃の6たちが音ズレちゃいますからタイフィリピンぬ牛丼でございます
どーん
3時はこの子のガリガリタッチが細身の俺が線牛丼を食べる
栄光の宗教
いろいろん
あ木下さんのビジョンを流した桜
ああああああ
あーなカラー美味しそうなお肉ねぇいただきます
og
いやも本当に食べるからねん
ウド杖もおいしいとをおいしいと
ああああああ
まずは入ってますよ謎維持ますよまだいきますよ
多分販売は行ったとー
ああああああああ
スマでぐっ
voodoo
ああああああ
負けてらんねー
俺は気を何としてでもクレイ
そしてまあもやしと java せねぇ
なめてたあとほんの少しなんですけどラストスパートがやばいん
th
ちょっともう夏芝です
ん
んえっ
持っています
謎
ううんっさあ
ee
me
ええええええ
俺ん
me
バッハ